hello and welcome to the new world
review where i'm gonna get all
psychological on your butt because i
have noticed things and now i have to
share them with you
this is the hunter hunter episode where
i actually use character names rather
than metaphorical versions of them and
make links to things they've done in the
past
because i have thoughts and feelings and
they will not be halted
and and and there are a lot of things to
talk about
so let's get into episode 70 and 71
episode 70 and we've decided that we
have a really good plan
a really important plan the plan to end
all plans and of course it's gone's plan
because whenever gone comes up with a
plan we can guarantee it will be simple
really simple because gone's really
simple not a simpleton
not stupid but simple he takes complex
concepts
and simplifies them down to their base
parts in this case the ultimate question
which is
who is stronger so we just need to smack
the ball really hard
or at least that's the case to gone
right and keel was there with broken and
busted fingers and these two kids know
that what they're doing is basically
killing each other slowly but hey
because i believe in you you're the only
one that can do this
i want to say that that was a really
heartfelt and beautiful moment and you
know what it was it was heartfelt and
beautiful and i loved it because it
showed how much their symbiotic
relationship bond is growing and how
quickly it's doing so if i'm entirely
honest there were a few tears on waifu's
face when i saw kilwa's reaction to god
knowing kilwa was hurt
but deciding to use him anyway because
he's the only one gone trust to hold
that dodge pool but
and yeah there's a butt cause if
sargeras didn't say anything
if everyone had just assumed gone could
and would do the thing again
the kilwa could do the thing again would
god have ever said anything about
kilwa's hands
would he have just used kilwa to get
what he wanted without the pep talk i
want to say yes i want to believe that
they have a really deep and meaningful
and heartfelt relationship that's based
on more than just being used but i
really don't think gon would have said
anything and i don't think he'd have
ever said anything beyond it kyoa hid
how hurt he was
he thought he was hiding from gone gone
knew the damage he's done so the balance
there is upset right one of them
innately holds power over the other
gone is as i discussed in an earlier
episode the primary
kilwa the secondary kiwa will do
anything for gone and gone has already
said that he wouldn't sacrifice anything
or everything i suppose for killah he's
already said he wouldn't and kilau has
already accepted it because frankly
kilwa's strength his physical strength
that is his mental strength
i mean that is debatable whether he even
has mental strength or a great deal of
mental strength and mental resilience
but anyway
that strength has come from being
tortured by those he's supposed to be
able to trust
and turn to for care which is his family
kilwa
perceives god's active decision to harm
him as
love because that's the only experience
he's ever had of love and
i'll qry i i use
i'm sure we'll go back to his family and
his parents eventually but if you're
tortured so intensely that your aura can
become electricity
at an age that concerns people who are
much much more experienced than you
maybe you're not a progeny
progeny prodigy maybe you're not a
prodigy maybe you're just a really
tortured kid and another kid is taking
advantage of you
and the more i think about this the more
i don't like it because of the
implications it has on the rest of the
series so far
gone questioned who he would sacrifice
in a binary situation way before even
taking the exam
then he met kilwa realized how much
potential he has
and we know how much he adores and can
pick our potential since we saw and
head-hunted zephyr
which was a huge point of passion for
him anyway he met kilwa but
at the last moment kilauea gets scared
off the exam by his brother and goes
home
gon doesn't like to leave potential
untapped i have to believe that he does
genuinely and deeply care for kiwa so he
goes to kilauea's home to get him to
return to the world and fulfill his
potential
but in doing that he tied kilwa to him
kilwa would have gone back to his life
and done something else
it would have sucked but gone following
him home to get him back out into the
world changed his life
forever every time gone reaffirms his
care for kilwa kiwa has a
huge emotional heart eyes reaction that
reaction is what i'm reacting to as an
audience member but
gone has kilwa wrapped up really neatly
because gone
has also been requesting more and more
of kiela and the major reasons gon
reaffirm that kilwa had to be the one to
hold the ball is because
a they do in fact have probably a good
synchronicity but b
and probably more important b it's a
good opportunity to say
i really care about you and i believe
you're the only one who can do this
thing where
you might never be able to use your
hands again but thank you
the art shifting form is a beautiful and
huge indication of gone deciding to be
serious about the situation but the
romantic softness of kilauea's responses
to god's seriousness makes me really
sorry for kilwa
the one who i'd argue is the more tender
and actually childlike and
moral of the two definitely we're seeing
more art of god's musculature developing
than we're seeing of kiewa who remains
the fashionista and more gentle
definitely the more thoughtful we spend
more time in his mind than we do in gons
if we think about it and
now that i do think about it i'm not
entirely sure we've spent any time in
god's mind
i do wonder why that is and i will
continue to wonder about that actually
i'll be honest
i didn't start out intending to detail
the potentially abusive relationship
between two kids but
hey this is where we are now and then we
add hisoka and everything is even more
messy am i right
talking about the episode in general
biski being out due to clothing is
absurd
and in terms of this dodgeball game
overall i'm getting grumpy with the
rules being shifted or revealed only
after they're broken it seems unfair
given how many rule sets we've been
explained
at length to now that they just wouldn't
be given rules
like everything's been explained it just
seems unfair
you know overall it's good energy it's
fun to be tense gone wants a full
victory in
true gone fashion and he's i don't see
why that wouldn't happen
ultimately especially now that keel was
pepped up i don't think kilwa could have
done it at all without gon's pep talk so
let's see what happens now
my final note will be read word for word
before we move on to the next episode
because this is literally what i wrote
as i watch the end of the episode
gone share a strong bond of trust and
hisoka has a strong bond with their
butts yes
i legitimately wrote that anyway episode
71
okay so i wasn't far off with gon kilwas
and hisoka's bonds
gone used everything else he had on
razer and passed out so hisoka did what
any loving schwinger would do and
helped gone get to his full win now i
have questions about hisoka's
motivations here hisoka notably focused
rather than finding razer's strength
thrilling in his own way
why is that hizoka's apparently more
discerning than i thought he was and
while that could have just been because
it streamlined the story for him not to
get all swingy with razor's power it's
interesting that hisoka's sexual
interest in power
wasn't deemed important enough for this
moment what a writer leaves out of a
narrative
is sometimes more interesting and
important than what they leave in so
what do we learn from hisoka's response
to razer it was fascinating to see that
hisoka actually gave gon his win while
sacrificing his own health and
verbally declaring that he was doing it
for gone without gone even able to see
what was happening this is the first
time we've seen hisoka do something in
absence of selfishness and i'm not sure
what that means for the character
it showed for sure that all three of the
people on the court at that point could
handle the amount of power thrown at
them but the fact that he did it
selflessly to give ghana win he thought
gone
deserved showed a level of sportsmanship
that we really haven't seen since the
hunter exam
when he made sure gone got to keep his
win after procuring he soaked his tag
we know or knew or i knew anyway that
hisoka is all about power
he's sexually interested in it but the
extent to which he goes for god's
benefit is something more
it's as though he genuinely cares about
god's well-being as it pertains to his
growth as a combatant and there's
something
really endearing and nice about that
nice on a wholesome level which isn't
really something i'd ever say about iski
of all people
the idea that hiskey has redeeming
features and that as
bisky notes he lies because he lies not
for any particular reason which is in
retrospect actually only half accurate
that he has those redeeming features at
all excites me because what
else has or would he do to keep these
kids safe what would he do for others
of course there's a selfishness to it he
wants gone to reach the fullest
potential he can so he can compare his
own ability to guns
but there has to be a time coming where
gone will in fact outmaneuver him the
power generated into that ball was all
gone
razer rebounding it didn't cut down the
energy enough it managed to break
hishoka's wrists regardless
and it managed to push razer out of
court back and forth if we look at
physics
that's a lot of power because i'm
physics now yes
the strength of that kid is intense and
growing and while he needs to spend more
time working on strategizing
if that strategy was his doing hisoka
has to realize that gone isn't far off
matching or surpassing his own abilities
sure he can think of ways to balance
things up and we haven't seen
necessarily hisoka's full capabilities
but as far as the narrative of a
repeatedly appearing team rocket type
archetype goes
hisoka's leaving that mould and becoming
more of a teacher the way biski is
i know that he wanted to kill gone when
he reached his full potential but he's
done so much to protect gone that i
wonder whether he actually could do it
when the time comes
it's in the same nature as becoming very
close to your livestock then not wanting
to butcher them
how does the disconnect happen when
that's something i'm excited to see
if and when it occurs meanwhile between
hisoka
and gone is killer truly doing all the
work to support the team
the brace and the cushion taking all
that impact in the way he does
perfectly balancing gon's raw power and
hisoka's cunning and sitting in the
middle of it all and yet kiwa will not
receive any of the accolade razer
noticed it though and i noticed it too
especially since if hisoka had decided
in that moment to double-cross them
kilwa would still have been there he
would have seen hisoka disappear and
would still have stay to support gone
metaphorically it's a beautiful image
gone focuses on one thing kilwa is there
watching gone's back and hisoka is there
to protect the potential until it's time
the combination of three powerful
entities all balancing out their
archetypes in one moment kilwa didn't
miss that moment either and didn't miss
what hisoka did for gone while he
invited hisoka to join out of suspicion
i can't imagine it was purely that
seeing hisoka do something for gone he
probably realized that they have similar
goals
look after and help our young super
saiyan achieve his goals which is
a hell of a combined motivation for two
people that love this one
boy and we found out some information
about jing ging jing this episode too
he's as much a monster as gone is gone
gets his psychopathic tendencies from
somewhere and now we know
it's his father who gathers people from
prisons and puts them in a game world to
kill
other hunters did he build the entire
game for his son if so what was he
intending to teach what's the lesson
gone learns from this beyond how to kill
a bomber he learns to treat the
characters in the game with enough
respect that he receives
items from them he learns to listen to
in-game narratives something kilwa has
ignored
in order to understand the world
something i think kiel was missing and
and that even i missed until now is that
jing wrote this game because he wrote it
he had a hand in creating all the
narratives
gone's intense focus on the story
elements is probably a combination of
actually enjoying game narrative but
also
everything he learns from the narrative
tells him something about his dad which
is kind of cool
every action every goal he needs to
conquer in the game to beat it requires
him to do something his dad
put in his way to gauge his abilities as
a human
and as a hunter if gon finds his dad
he's worthy of him
which we always knew but he's worthy of
him as a person
not just as a hunter and that's
different and finally
that he has the real patch of sure shows
that genthru simply doesn't think a
little kid could be powerful enough to
have a real card
over a copy here we go again with the
underestimating of little kids our
favorite trope of this entire series
it feels as though we're already nearing
the climax of this arc we're just in the
build and it hasn't felt as intense
this arc as it did last one but i guess
with the kids it ramps up much faster
and doesn't get dark until a bit later i
guess it's time to plan to deal with
both the game his dad wrote and the
bomber that could touch them and kill
them i wonder if sargeras will be able
to keep gentry away from them
or if he'll just sidestep and come for
them immediately and
you know get in the way of the plan
whatever that is it'll be simple
probably we'll see and i guess we'll
we'll find out next time because that's
it from me
if you enjoyed this deep dive into
motivation and intense psychological
awkwardness
feel free to click here here and here
you can also click here and here and
hang out on the discord have a great day
and i'll see you next time